MARK MIRCHANDANI:
As companies start
to collect large amounts of data
from an ever-increasing number
of locations, building
a data pipeline
can be quite the challenge.
Join us as we talk to Two Sigma
about how they architected
a data pipeline to
fit their many demands
on this episode of Stack Chat.
Thanks for joining us.
Tell us a little bit
more about Two Sigma
and why your data pipeline
was so complex to build.
TONY WALKER: Sure.
So at Two Sigma, we make use
of data science and technology
to uncover value.
Essentially, we can buy
massive amounts of data
along with computing power
and financial expertise
to develop sophisticated
training models.
We need to ingest and process
data at an ever-increasing rate
whilst protecting it
from infiltration,
either accidental or malicious.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So can you show us
how you were able to keep
up with the demands of so
much data?
TONY WALKER: Sure.
Let's take a look at a diagram.
Our first attempt at this was
to have a GCP project which
was connected to the internet.
This allowed us to
arrange for vendor data
to be ingested from various
sources, such as S3 or FTP.
This enabled us to have
an environment where
our researchers were able to
explore datasets and discover
new features.
From there, our engineers
could build data pipelines
using native services like
BigQuery, Google Cloud Storage,
and Dataproc or Dataflow.
This enabled us to
rapidly derive insights
from the data in a
more scalable manner
when compared to our
on-premise environment.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
You mentioned earlier
that you needed to
protect the data.
Can you tell us more
about how you dealt
with that in this environment?
TONY WALKER: As you can
imagine, the security
of our intellectual property,
both internal and external,
is of paramount importance.
As a result, any operations that
deal with the movement of data
in or out of the
company's network
must be as secure as possible.
So the most significant
concern with this design
was the fact that the project
was connected to the internet.
Although this made it
easy to ingest data,
it also forced us to
isolate our engineers
within the environment.
We essentially allowed them to
use native services, but only
from instances
within the project,
essentially creating
a DMZ-like setup.
This was a pain because
it required us to maintain
two separate IM identities--
one with full privileges, and
one with heavy restrictions
that could be used
safely on site.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You mentioned
handling the import of data
from lots of locations.
How did you accomplish this?
And did you see any
impact from dealing
with the size of this data?
TONY WALKER: So dealing with
multiple sources was relatively
easy.
In some cases, we
had automated jobs,
which would collect data
from sources such as FTP.
In many other cases, we were
able to leverage the storage
transfer service for
interacting with vendors
which share the data via S3.
This was great, as it
removed the need for us
to build anything
bespoke for the job.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Going back
to security, how did you
ensure that only the right
people could access your data?
TONY WALKER: The
key change we made
is that the product is now
part of a secure perimeter.
This is a concept from
the secure VPC product.
Essentially, it allows us
to have fine-grained control
over who has access to data
stored within BigQuery and GCS.
The other key difference is
that we use private interconnect
between Two Sigma and Google.
With that in place, we
could enable engineers
and researchers to safely access
the data using native tools
directly from within Two
Sigma, without the risk
it could be shared outside.
The other bonus with
private interconnect
was that we had dedicated
bandwidth for data transfers.
Ultimately, the new
architecture was a game changer
for our data engineering team.
They could now
operate independently
without impacting anyone
else within the company.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Now, this has
been running well for a while.
And you've learned
a lot along the way.
If you could go back
and do it again,
what would you do differently?
TONY WALKER: Well, one thing
we've rather glossed over
so far is the way in
which we ingest data
in the new environment.
The secure VPC product
makes it very easy
to lock down where our
data can be accessed from,
but it also introduces a
new level of complexity
when dealing with getting
data from external sources.
This also required
us to think carefully
about how secure API traffic
is routed between Two
Sigma and these projects.
In order to do this, we
implemented a secure VPC
concept called bridging.
This allowed us to
use a single product
as the gateway for all
other secure traffic, which
has eased management,
but presents us
with a new bottleneck,
which we have concerns
with in the long-run in
terms of scalability.
This is something
we'll look to address
as we on-board more teams.
So by architecting
carefully, we were
able to handle large volumes
of unpredictable external data,
combine those with our internal
data sets, and stay secure.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks
so much for giving us
some insight into how you built
your data pipeline to handle
all of these challenges.
TONY WALKER: My pleasure.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: If you'd like
to get some hands-on experience
and try setting up a VPC
perimeter for yourself,
check out the quick
guide in the description.
Thanks for watching.
And make sure to subscribe
to the Google Cloud Platform
channel for more great content.
We'll see you next
time on Stack Chat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]